♪ ♪
>> Greg:ID BLY THINK
NOING COULD BEINERND THENA SECR?
[LAUGHTER]I'M JUST GOING TO SIT.
HE WAS THE INE GENERAL WHO
GAVEEIJING A RINGYING-DING
>> I LOVE AT.
>> Greg: A RIGHT, ACCORDINGTO AY
BOB WOODWARD AND BOB COSTA,
CHAIRMAN MARK MILLEYAS SO
FEFUL TRUMP WOU START AAR
WIHINA, WHICH IS AURD,
THAT HE SECRETLY CLED A TOP
CHINESE GERAL TWICESSURING
M TRUMP WOULD NOT ATTK.
IT WLD HAVE BEEN NICE IFE
HAD ASKED TO STOP RELSINGDEADLYL
OVER THE WORLD,UTOU KNOW,
MAYBE NEXT PHONCALL.
EVORE DAMNING, MILYREPORTEDLY TE
GOING TO AACK, I'M GNG TO
CALL YOU HAD A TE."
SO WHAT DID HE SAY WHEN THE
INESE CALLED HIM BACK?"HOLD ON,T
TABAN'S --
LINE ONE."
MILLEY'S CALLS WE NOT SECRET,
IT HAPPENE ALL THE TIME BETWE
MITARY LEARS, AND THOUG NOT
SO MUCH OF TH GOOD ONES.
I DOUBT PATN EVER MESSAGE HIM
ON LKEDIN -- I DON'T THINK
LINKED IAND EXISTED BAC THEN,
BU YOU GET THEOINT.
TRY TELLING MILLES DEFENRS
IN THEEDIA.
>> I'M SORRY,EPUBLICANS DON'TLII
I'VE JUST GOT TO ASK, ARE YOU SO
STUPID, ARE YOUO IGNORANT OF
HOW THINGS WOR THAT YOUON'T
KNOWHAT FROM TIMEO TIME,
GENERALS TALK T GENERS.
THIS I GOING TO PLAY OUT
ON TWIER.
THIS IS GOINGO BE COMPLETELY
POLARIZED.
IT'S EHER GOING TO BE, YOU
KNOW, GENAL MILLEY IS
TRAITO OR A PATRI VEHIC
TH HAS ALREADY STARTEDO
OCCUR.
LET'S STICK TO THE FACTS
E FACTS ARE WE HAVAN
UNBALANCED PREJUCE PREDENCY.
>> GOD BLESS GENERAL MILY FOR
STRAIGHTING THINGS OUT.
I KNOW THE CHA OF COMMAND AS
SACROSANCT, BUTHIS IS AN
EMERGENCY.
>> Greg: IOULD LISTEN TO HER
FOR NEVER
ONE MAN CALLING HIM OUT WAS ALEX
VINDMAN, SAYG "IF THIS IS TRU
TR, GENERAL MILLEY MUS
REGN, YOU CAN SIMPLY WALK AY
OM THAT."
THINK ABOUT HOW HE WALKEDWAY
FROMFGHANISTAN.
HE IS WALKINGISASTER WHO I
MORE CONCERNED ABO THE
FEELINGS O THE AUTHOR OF "WHITE
FRAGILITY" THE HE DOESHE
OFFICEHE COMMANDS, AND HE SURES.
SO MAYBE HE SHOUL WALK.
WHATO YOU THINK, TERRENCE?
SHOULD HE RESIGN AT THISOINT?
>> YOU KNOWHAT, GENERAL SIL
LLEY --
IS MAN ISRAITOR -- YES,E
IS.
>> Greg: WOW, THATS PRETTY
STRONG.>> THAT IPRETTY STRONG AD
THAT IS WHAT BELIEVE AND TT
IS WHA IT IS, IELIEVE.
>> Greg: THO ARE N FANS OF
MILLEY.
>> FIR OF ALL, IT MADE ME SICK
TO MY STOMACH THAALL THESE
PELE STABBED TRU IN THE BK
OF YOUR YOU GO BEHINDISACK,
CALLG CHINA -- YOURE MORE
RRIEDBOUT CNA THEN YOU A
ABOUT OUR PEOPLE IN AFGHANISTAN
YOU ARE NOT PATRIOT --
>> Greg: THAT'S A GD POINT.
YOU ARE NOT A TE AMERICAN.
IS IS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
D ACTUALLY, H SHOULD BE
ARRESTED
IEAN, HE ADMITTED TO CALLING
CHINA, A THEN CLAIMED HE IS
GOING TO GIVE THEMARNING IF
WE ARE GOING TTTACK.
WHOSE SIDERE YOU ON?
>> Greg: OKAY, B THIS GETS
TO AOINT, SHARY A LOT OF
THIS DOES SOUND KIND OF CZY.
DO YOU THINK AOT OF THIS IS
JUSTIKE -- FORXAMPLE, WHO
TUALLY THINKS THAT WE WERE
GOING TO INVADE CHINA?
THIS SOUS LIKE SOMETHING
WOODWA WOULD HAVE MADE UP.
IF EVERYTHIN IS TRUE, TERRENCE
IS RHT, BUT WT IF ITS NOT
TR?
ITS SO OUTRAGEOUS.
DO YOU BUY THIS?>>EFORE I ANSWEM
REALLY EMBARRASSEDECAUSE WHEN
YOUR STAFF SD WEERE TALNG
ABOUT MILLEY, IM THINKING
LLEY VANILLY.
GENERAL MILLEYAY HAVE HAD SOME
SECRETS T HIDE.
YOU BRINGP A GOOD POINT ABOUT
WOODRD.
I ACTUALLY PERNALLY KNOW
SOMEE WHO IS DIRECTLYUOTED
IN A WOODWARD BOO WHO NEVERSPOKT
CORRECTED CAUSE THE QUOT WAS
WRONAND COULD NOT GET THAT
FID.IHINK IT RINGS A LITTL BIT
UE, BUT --
>> Greg: CAN I ASK YOU A
QUESTION?
WHY IS- I AM THEOST OF THESHOW .
>>reg: HOWO PEOE KEEP
HAVING WOODWARD IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?I MEAN, TRUMP EVEN N
THE WHE HOUSE.WHERE DOES HEIT?
WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE, I
NEVER SAW WOODWARD THE.
ERE IS H ALL THE TE DNG
IS STUFF?
>> DIDT HE INTERVIEW THE
FORMER CIA DIRECR ON HIS
DEATHBEDBUT NOBODY S HIM
COME IN OR O OF THE HOSPIT?
>> Gre YEAH.
I WANHAT KIND OF JOB.
YOU DON'T HAVTO DO ANYTHG.HE IS.
>> Greg: YES.
TYRUS,HOUGHTS?
I, YOU KNOW, I JUST EL LIKE
ISHOLE THING IS, WELL, WHAT
IS THE WOR I'M LOOKING FOR --
LEEP].
[APPLAUSE]
THERE IS NO RSON FOR MILLEY TO
SIGN BECAUSE HE IS GHT WHERE
HE SHOULD BE I THISADMINISTTION.
WHAT WE ARE SEEINGS WHAT WE
ARE GETTING, AND LEAVING HIM
GOING IS GOI TO BE MORE O THE
SA THING.
TO SUCCEED IN THIS NEW
ADMINIRATION, YOU HE TO BURY
EVERYTHING THAT WASN T LASTADMI.
THAT IS NUMBEONE.
TWO, I NEVER THOUGHT W WERE
DEFCON 5 WITH CHINA.
IF TRUMP IS THBULLY THAT YOUSAYU
DO NOT WALK UP  THE OTHER 6'8"
GUY ANDAY "WHAT'S UP, BROWHAT D"
YOU GO TO THE 5'4" GUY,
NOH KOREA OR SOMEPCE SMALL
KE THAT AND GO "HEY!"
THAT WOULD B IN LINE WITH THISIY
TALK ABO PRESIDENT TRUMP THE
ME WAY A LOT OF MYXES TALK
OUT ME.
VERY UNFORABLE.
I'M DERANGED.
I HA DELUSIONS OF GRANDEUR.
I ACTED BUF BUT I WAS REALLY
CHUNKY
THEY WOULD SAY JUST UNFLAERING
INGS THAT COULD BE TRUE, COU
NOTE TRUE, BUT NO MATTER WHAT,
MAKES ME LK LIKE A JERK.EVEN PRL
WA I DON'T KNOW WHAT YO DID
TO HIM, BUT IT WAS LIKE, IF THIS
TRULY HAPPED, THEN I WOULD
HAVE FIRED HIM AND HE HDLED IT
LIKE AN ALT.
HE IS N GIVING THEM WHAT THEY
AR USED TOO, STHEY HAVEO
EXUND, Y KNOW.
I DON'T THINK MILLE H BEEN ON
THPHONE WITH ANYBO ME THAN5 MIN.
I JT CAN'T SEE TS DUDE DOING
THAT.
HE ISART O THE WOKE
ADNISTRATION, W CHANGE H
STY, AFGHANISTAN IS ON
ENOUGH
>> Greg:T COULD HAVE
HAENED SO FAR -- LE, KAT,
YBE HE THOUGHTE WOULD BE
SEEN AS A HERO, BUT HERE'S TH
THIN IF WE HA KNOWN ABOUTTHIS EE
BEEN GONE AND WE WOULDN' HAVETH.
>> YH, I JUST THI TAKING THE
BIGGER PICRE --
>> Greg: DON'T DO TT.
>> I'M GOI TO DO IT.
>> Gg: I DON'T WANTHE BIG
PICTURE.
>> WELL, THIS GUY DOE.
MILLEYLIKE, HE REALLY, REALLYSU.
>> Greg: YES.
>> REAY JUST SUCKS A HIS JOB.
ALL THO LITTLE SCARS HE WE,
HE GOT FROM ING ABOUT A WAR
JUSTO HE COULD G THOSETARS.
AT THE EXPENSE OAMERICAN LIV
LIVE
WI THIS STORY ON THIS WHO
NEWS CLE, DID THI HAPPE OR
NOT HAPPE SHOULD HE BE FIRED
OR N FIRED?
I'M JU SITTING HERE LIKE,AN
SOMEONE PLEASE EXPLAIN TO ME
WH REGARDLESS OF TH EVEN,THATHI?
>> Greg: THAT'S E WHOLE
THING.AT SOUTH CAPONE GETTING BI
GO.
>> IOT FIR FROM A RUBYTUESDAY RE
BUSINE OF SDING YOUNG PPLE
TO DIE.
>> Greg: THAT IS TE.WELL,AVE YOF
THEIR APPS
>> THANKOU.
>> Greg: I LOVE ME EVE
TUESDA
>> I STILL EAT THE AFTER THEY
FIREDE.
Greg: IS NOT NAMED AER A
ROLLING STONES SG?
I DON KNOW.
>> IID NOT READ THROU ALL OF
THE PAMPHTS.
>> Greg: THERE INO RUB